avec la montée de la pauvreté ces
derniers mois les initiatives solidaires
se multiplient la dernière en date
s'appelle les paniers suspendus inspiré
de ce qui se fait en italie et l'idée
aider les personnes démunies en déposant
dans la rue nourriture et produits
d'hygiène et ça marche déjà 25 lieux
dans l'agglomération tourangelle lucas
chopin
ne vous y trompez pas bouard amrane le
saut ne met pas ses surplus au débarras
il alimente son panier suspendu le
concept est simple déposés devant chez
soi des produits alimentaires ou de
première nécessité à disposition des
personnes les plus précaires aux 133 de
la rue marat à tours on peut trouver de
nombreux produits offerts par boivent et
ses voisins un segment alimentaire
hygiène un segment culture livres jouets
et un segment donc vestimentaire au delà
même ces textiles puisqu'on a aussi des
chaussures et des couvertures qui
souvent sont déposées dans les paniers
l'idée vient d'italie et s'est imposé
comme une évidence pour l'enseignant de
43 ans pendant le premier confinement
avec une amie on s'est questionné sur
quel sens on allait donner à ce
confinement
au regard de ce qui se passe dans la
société et
en recherchant sur les réseaux on a vu
cette opération qui était simple
efficace et relativement locale
il existe pour le moment 25 paniers
suspendus comme celui de boue afd
entoure et ses environs et tous sont
victimes de leur succès les paniers se
vident très très vite on a des retours
positifs et effectivement c'est une
nécessité
et ces complémentaires aux actions qui
sont menées par rapport aux associations
qui font un travail déjà relativement
formidable a aujourd'hui bois fapel plus
que jamais les citoyens à créer leur
propre panier suspendu et à les
répertorier sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'opération